[Music]
october is nigh
and the month is kicking off with a trio
of huge games
this episode of new releases is taking a
look at the whole month so strap in for
platforming mascots
spaceships and dystopian adventures
let's take a look at a few of the
hottest games launching in the new month
kicking things off on day one is none
other than mario himself
with super mario bros 35 this is a 35
player battle royale version of classic
mario brothers
so every enemy you defeat gets sent to
an opponent's screen
last plumber's standing wins as you
might have guessed from the name
super mario bros 35 is celebrating the
series 35th anniversary
and it'll be available as a free
download for nintendo switch online
members
starting thursday october 1st just be
aware that this game will
go away after march 31st of next year
and now for mario's retro rival crash
bandicoot
crash 4 it's about time is dropping at
the top of the month
bringing a whole new suite of
challenging levels to jump and spin
through as crash
coco neocortex and even dingodile and
tauna
you can unlock bonus flashback levels
and an inverted mode that remixes the
stages you already conquered
and expect to bend all sorts of physics
with the new masks too crash 4 lands on
ps4 and xbox one on friday october 2nd
now let's head to a galaxy far far away
with star wars squadrons
if you've been itching to get back into
the cockpit of a tie fighter or x-wing
now's your chance this game has a story
mode pitting the rebels against the
empire
deathmatch style multiplayer dog fights
and capture point based fleet battles
squadrons takes flight on ps4 xbox one
and pc on the second
and yes you can fly in vr if you've got
the headset for it
just remember to wear your helmet for
safety have you been
fine sir good it's a good thing you were
wearing that helmet
yeah back on earth
things are getting dicey and watchdogs
legion the open world adventure is set
in a dystopian future where the city of
london
is under the military rule of the albion
company fortunately
dedsec is here to fight against them and
you can recruit characters to the cause
as you carry out missions however you
want across the city
which characters can you recruit that's
the thing watchdogs legion lets you play
as
anyone if you can get them on your side
you can build your team on ps4 xbox one
pc and stadia on thursday the 29th
and yes there will be ps5 series x and
series s versions later too
we started the month at nintendo and
we're going to close there too thanks to
pikmin 3 deluxe
this re-release includes the original
pikmin 3 all of its dlc
and a new set of side missions for
olomar and louis there are also new
co-op options too
so you can once again explore the planet
pluck pikmin and collect spaceship parts
with a friend
pikmin 3 deluxe comes to switch on
friday the 30th closing out the month
and those are some of the hottest games
launching all month long as always
remember that release dates are based on
retailer listings and are subject to
change
thanks for watching everyone and i'll be
back with a closer look at more october
games next sunday
[Music]